et le rend compte et acteur pardon
françois bégaudeau acteur principal du
film de laurent cantet entre les murs
qui a obtenu la palme d'or est notre
invité de pick and françois bégaudeau
bonsoir merci d'être un autre compagnie
cette palme est elle pour vous une
divine surprise
dans l'absolu au moment où on s'est
rencontré avec laurent il ya deux ans et
demi et qu'on a commencé à réfléchir à
comment faire ce film où il a
effectivement la panne c'était très très
loin mais après on a fini par les
sélectionner et puis des rumeurs courent
et puis on s'est rendu compte le film
était bien reçue par la presse par les
gens qui l'avait vu dans les projections
donc ça commençait à devenir crédible et
en fait ça l'était puisqu'on a eu la
palme d'or je tiens à l'annoncé le
président du jury sean penn avait
annoncé sa volonté de récompenser les
filmant en phase avec la société
entre les murs c'est justement un film
de société c'est un film sur la jeunesse
aujourd'hui à wemmel à vous dit deux
choses qui pour l'instant sont très
différentes je préfère très largement
dire que c'est un film sur la jeunesse
qu'un film de société parce que ça ça
fait peur tout là tout le monde on a
l'impression que ça va passer avant les
dossiers de l'écran
donc ouais moi je trouve que le ski a
été à l'origine du film vraiment c'est
l'amour qu'à laurent pour la jeunesse
pour la ville aime observer
l'adolescence il l'avait déjà fait et
moi j'avais écrit le livre à peu près
fin disons mû par cette même cette même
passion pour la vitalité adolescente et
votre volonté c'est justement de donner
une autre image de la jeunesse
aujourd'hui je sais pas est ce que est
ce que tu penses qu'on a donné une bonne
image de la jeunesse dans ce film rachel
rachel donc une bonne image qu'il faut
donner tout simplement on a
on a bien montré comment étaient des
élèves vont un peu agitée mais en tout
cas moi je trouve qu'on a bien joué un
hutois but récompense quoi qu'est-ce que
ça va changer c'est d'abord d'être avec
rachel je pense que je pense que c'est
très bien représenté dans ce film d'un
mot qu'est-ce que cela va changer
d'après vous la palme d'or par rapport à
la carrière du film et à vous aussi par
rapport à ben je pense que tout
simplement le film va être plus vu qu'il
n'aurait été s'il n'avait pas eu voilà
donc il va être beaucoup vu je crois et
par beaucoup de gens très différents
donc on est on est ravi parce qu'on est
on est content de présenter notre boulot
parce qu'on est assez content de ce
qu'on a fait donc voilà françois
bégaudeau merci d'avoir été notre invité
par la queue